my class went to a local vet's office we
got to see the exam rooms and play with
some puppies then they took us to an
operating room and brought in a cat we
watch them and necess eyes the cat shave
its stomach and slice its belly open to
prepare to spay it I don't know what
happened next because I passed out we
went to an indoor trampoline park but
didn't get to bounce on anything just
got to listen to the owner talk about
what it's like to own a business my
class had to go to a funeral parlor we
wrote our own obituaries picked out
coffins and practiced mourning my fourth
grade class took a trip to a plantation
house to learn more about Georgia's
history it was really nice and authentic
but there was one activity where they
slipped the class up to do different
things they made all the people of color
go out in the field and pick cotton
while all the white kids got to play
dress-up in the house our field trip was
to the back of the school we sat on the
asphalt listening to someone explained
to us what the different numbers on
plastic containers meant we went on a
field trip to a dairy farm we got to
help milk the cows and help feed the
calves the next step on the trip was an
abattoir where we watched the cows
unloaded killed and then went to the
room where they cut out the bones after
that we went to lunch where we were
served beef pies it was not a
well-planned day